any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
it is a great thrill to have
my colleague and uh and friend craig
calendar of the department of philosophy
at uc san diego
and the director of the institute for
practical ethics is that correct is that
the correct title for it that's correct
wow well you're joining us uh on the end
of the impossible podcast at the end of
february we are both vaccinated at least
uh partially vaccinated and coveted free
in case our boss pradeep koshla or gavin
newsom might be watching who knows he he
sometimes tunes in i know for sure uh
but it's a great thrill to have you here
thank you well thanks for having me it's
wonderful to be here yeah we've
interacted for at least the last 10
years on various thesis committees and
other affairs and today we're going to
be talking about a book that i've had
uh been reading for several years
because it's so much fun to read and
reread and that's a time a graphic novel
i believe that's the title of that of
that book and then you have another book
that we'll talk about as well
uh so the first question i have for you
is um what made you think was a tenure
that allowed you the freedom to write a
graphic novel are graphic novels
considered serious academic fare oh uh
that's a good question and and one
you'll uh the answer you'll relate to
yeah so i was living in london and i
just uh we just bought a house my first
house
and we had just had our first child
and
i thought well i can't really get any
work done with a new brand new baby uh
in the house but the baby would go to
sleep like from two to four in the
afternoon every day
and i thought well i'll write this
cartoon book because i can't really do
any kind of real research
and also i you know i thought
you know i work so much on time
if i need to go to a library or look up
stuff then it's already getting too hard
for a cop for a cartoon book and so i
was able to just punch the thing out
during nap times
for the first month or two of uh my
first one's uh existence
and now he's all grown up right he's
about to start college or he's in
college yeah he's just great wow oh he
just graduated wow that is true what
they say time does fly
and although i say and and you're the
perfect person to ask this up i think
that
time is is super relative in that uh
various increments of time
fly but other aspects of time drag on
and if you remember back to the days
when he was in diapers or whatever
uh sometimes you would like as the other
cartoon novel called go the f to sleep
uh mentions that sometimes you just want
to go to bed and that period between you
know dinner time bath time story time
bedtime falling asleep getting up
wanting water
take that drags on and yet then you turn
around and you're like he's a graduate
student like
how is it the psychological arrow of
time how is that uh relative it would
seem that you could have at most one
concept one thermodynamic error we'll
talk about one cosmic error of time it's
not like there's multiple ones of those
or are there
yeah there are many arrows and regarding
the psychological experience of time
yeah when we talk about time flowing
fast or slow or that i mean there's so
many variables going on
and then one one of the big ones of
course is whether you're it's uh
you know something that has been encoded
in memory and it's a kind of
retrospective judgment or is it one you
know so about ongoing
moments
and you know so this is something that's
very familiar to many of us who are
fortunate enough to just
you know have the pandemic be such that
we are stuck at home and in the same
routine
we think you know how could it be friday
again already it just went by like that
and of course then we're doing a kind of
retrospective judgment over the week
basically nothing happened you know
compared to the previous week and so if
you think of each tick of the
psychological clock as being a kind of
uh
measuring salient events
there weren't that many and so there
weren't that many top uh ticks so it
feels like it's uh you know going really
fast
on the other hand in the moment you know
it might be feel like going really
slowly
you know it might be seem to drag on and
so it depends on what's going on
uh of course you know for other people
in the pandemic if you know if you're a
nurse at a hospital or something it
might be a very very different
experience
and so this uh i'd always say you know
when it comes to
the psychological uh you know how long
the psychological under uh feeling of
duration
as far as i can see it it varies with
every single variable that's ever been
measured
yeah have you just had orange juice
have you had
coffee alcohol
mind altering drugs
it changes all of those things to change
your sense of duration
and of course you know there's no one
better to talk about the peregrinations
in time than uh than einstein who is a
character in the book in the graphic
novel
as well as uh galileo and then
furthermore we're going to talk about uh
kurt gertle as well because
little known we know about his
incompleteness theorem and we know in my
mind at least people in physics you
often hear about like someone so has
physics envy or a field has physics envy
you know
recapitulating freud's penis envy or
what have you uh and um but people say
oh so-and-so field has physics envy but
i think physics has math envy and maybe
math has philosophy envy so i want to
start off in that provocative vein um
the fact that we can't really prove
something in physics i mean you're free
to please disabuse me if i'm wrong but i
feel like we don't prove things correct
in physics we can prove things wrong in
physics we can falsify things as popper
provided this demarcation hypothesis
but on the other hand we can't prove
things as well as mathematician can
prove something and i think now uh is
sort of needed more than ever the
clarification of what science
is and what pseudoscience is and what it
is not and i wonder if you can sort of
talk from a philosopher's point of view
but also i see you as a very physics
adjacent philosopher very deep training
maybe before we move into that i'm sorry
to be so uh jumping around in time and
space but you inspire me
first tell us what is your background
exactly how long have you been here
where were you before here what's your
world line as you talk about in the book
what's your past light cone look like
okay uh that's a very unlikely world
line i think
uh yeah so i was uh so neither of my
parents you know went to college so i'm
not sort of coming up in like where
academia was sort of a thing i would
think of doing
um and i was supposed to be a printer
so my great-grandfather grandfather and
father were all printers and so you know
just do a little bit of induction on
that and all the mail calendars were
printers
so it seemed clear what i was going to
do
but then this thing got invented and
became popular
called the computer
and the uh you know the print industry
did not seem to be such a great
uh industry to go into anymore you know
this kind of skilled labor that was
special to printing was then not
going to be valued as much because you
could do something almost as good for so
much cheaper with the computer
and so then you know given that
background it seemed like i should be
either a doctor or a lawyer and i
started off in biochemist biology and
chemistry
uh but boy you know once i hit college
there were so many interesting things
and i just bounced around from one major
to another so i
almost became a math major
uh i almost became an art major i did
become a psychology major for a brief
brief brief moment where were you a
student uh providence college oh so they
gave me a uh
yeah so they gave me a scholarship which
was nice yeah and uh
yeah in rhode island also i'm from rhode
island which part uh providence so i was
in brown yeah so yeah we probably
overlapped at one point or another maybe
on the home visit or something like that
uh yeah that's wonderful yeah so it was
providence promises
and so you went from there yeah so then
i uh but i always had you know yeah so i
would get uh my uncle would give me
uh uncle and they would give me uh gift
certificates to the brown university
bookstore
and i would i was always reading the
great bookstore and my mother is
still but especially back then obsessed
with science fiction
and so i would read a lot of that too
because there's a lot of that in the
house
and so this always kind of put me in
this more kind of philosophy of physics
trajectory
and then i went to uh
rutgers university which was one of the
uh it was one of the best places to go
it still is in philosophy
and they happened to have all these
great philosophers of physics there and
so i just oh and then i went so yeah so
what really triggered things then to go
into philosophy of physics was
i went to a popular talk by david murman
uh where he was explaining bell's
theorem
one of those kind of simple coloring
theorems
so anybody could understand it right and
i i walked out of that lecture and i
just couldn't believe it
and i thought well if you're interested
in philosophy and metaphysics in the
world
here's this experiment that is like
really experimental metaphysics it's so
interesting
and i basically dropped everything and
then started just reading quantum
mechanics and reading it reading it and
then happened to be in a place where i
could
you know where it was just fantastic i
mean all these great people
not just at rutgers but princeton and
in new york who work in this area and so
it was really just
really super lucky that i was able to be
there and do that and then after that um
did you have to what's typical in
philosophy is it postdoc or what was
your thesis by the way what was the
title of your thesis right now
explaining time's arrow okay so it was
about uh
a lot of it was about quantum mechanics
and uh yeah and philosophy well it's
changing a little bit the discipline now
where there are more post docs and
things like that but back then
it was crueler or kinder depending on
how you look at it you're either gonna
if you weren't especially if you were in
a kind of nichey
field like philosophy physics uh you
were probably either gonna go to some
really you know a research school
because a small liberal arts college
doesn't need a philosopher physics or
you're going to work at mcdonald's
and so
if you're trying to the other and since
there weren't any postdocs you found out
fast right
and so i i was lucky you know so you
mentioned uh popper
and so you know popper died i think in
94.
and in 96 i took a job at the london
school of economics and they had that
center for philosophy of science that
founded i guess and uh
yeah and then at some point i got sick
of
the rain and came here so i've been here
for over 20 years oh wow say you're uh a
longer timer than myself i got here in
2004.
and i became aware of you not too long
after that actually coming and being in
some committees and i met our colleague
david meyer and others through you
um and of course you have uh you know a
gift for not only
researching and mentorship in this field
but also in terms of leadership and
authorship which i think is an important
part of what we do as a scientist and as
as public servants in a sense and kind
of demystifying science and
distinguishing it from science and
pseudoscience and i was excited to learn
of your upcoming course which i may sit
in on i've done that before some of our
fellow faculty as i mentioned you're my
first ucsd you're not my first ucsd
fellow professor my first non-relative
ucsd professor so there's been some
nepotism i'm hoping to have our
chancellor and other people come on the
show
but it's always a treat to do things in
person and i was saying beforehand you
know or earlier in this conversation you
know we kind of have this envy of
mathematicians at least some of us in
physics because at least there's the
bounds of what can be proven and
actually things can be proven you can
prove for matt's last theorem right you
can prove the pythagorean theorem but
you can't prove that you know einstein
is right to arbitrary you know accuracy
um so
i think that we use popper as kind of a
substitute for girdle and i wonder if
you could kind of um you know
distinguish for me or tell me if i'm
wrong in that sense as scientists we
kind of rely
so much on poppers falsification
demarcation and maybe you can explain
what that is that we lose sight of the
fact that even popper didn't fully
support demarcation and falsification as
the cinequan none of what science is so
how did he get to be so elevated how did
popper get to this exalted level where
people will say things like string
theory and things are not only not
correct they're bad for science they're
bad science they might as well be
pseudoscience
yeah so it's kind of funny because uh
popper is you know what you go to for uh
demarcation so you want to separate the
good science from the bad good good
theory from bad theory
popper was of course a creature of his
time you know you had in philosophy all
this kind of
you know hegel and all this stuff which
is very hard to make sense of
you don't even know if it's making sense
sometimes
but then also he saw uh
not marxism so much the economic side
but the sort of marxist theory
dialectical materialism thank you and uh
and freud
all of this is nonsense
and then you know came up with a uh this
demarcation criterion of falsifiability
um and of course for him you know
einstein's uh the eddington experiment
in 1919
for you know uh vindicating uh
confirming einstein's uh
uh you know the uh bending of light
around the sun
this was amazing yeah because that was a
bold risky hypothesis right it's not it
was not a given that that was going to
turn out that way he thought you know
you look at that and then you look at
freud and right you know you noticed
astrology right psychology
uh but anyway yeah so popper's super
famous for this
no philosopher of science likes the
demarcation criterion from popper we all
can't stand it uh
and it's kind of funny that it gets used
so much in the outside world yeah but
then the philosophy of science uh we
don't use it at all
uh you know it's very problematic you
know because we can think of
well first is the bull part and
falsifiable
what makes it you know not just unfalse
not
false false but unfalsifiable
uh
you know in some sense you could make
any theory uh
falsifiable or unfalsifiable if you take
care of them
also you can think of a lot of things
yeah so like string theory as it's
coming up well it's not
it's not you can't directly subject it
to empirical confirmation
uh but on the other hand you know the
goal will always
was you know was to do that and so is it
unfulfillable or not
also you can think of things you know
astrology is just false right but it's
uh but right yes so therefore it's
science right
yeah i have a big problem with that as
well it's not very good or the earth is
flat okay that's my theory okay i can
falsify it with simple measurements
therefore it's scientific i mean it's
nonsense yeah so it's not a very good
criterion and
so now i think you know there's sort of
i don't really know exactly but you know
i think most philosophers of science
think that there's like
kind of set of things that you look for
in theory
and you know they
you know they might be you know how unif
unified they are how how much how much
how fruitful they are how predictive
they are
and you'll not allow for tolerances and
all those things
there's some sort of rough metric we use
when we do this right
i think in
there's a kind of more like
picture i get i think you get more from
history and not so much philosophy where
they really think of it as more like
just at a time
it's our stamp of disapproval
on that right you know and that changes
with time history yes it's of
fashion that so we use it it's just a
kind of
insulting blah right that's right popper
said which is an appeal to authority
which we don't hold yeah so popper
didn't like
so you know so they would then interpret
poppers thing is basically that popper
didn't like freud
[Music]
and you know but if you have this kind
of multi-criterialist thing you'd say
well freud's theory didn't actually
wasn't successful predicting anything it
didn't you know failed in all sorts of
different ways flexible
too flexible yeah so there's like these
kind of signs of when you think of
really cheesy through the science
uh
you know uh then you see this kind of
overly flexible
uh that can accommodate anything
what i always like to point out is you
know popper hated uh he hated astrology
or you know this is the thing he hated
freud as you just said or he was against
foreign he was against astrology he was
against dialectic materialist and then
marxism and then if you go to like most
countries there are far more
marxist socialist countries on earth and
there are capitalist democracies on
earth there are far more you know
psychologists in the world practicing
dream interpretation all the things he
hated and you can find much more inc in
your you know sunday newspaper about
astrology than astronomy
and so it's like even popper has been
falsified by this
exactly the durability of the
subject
so but again yeah i mean we're kind of
you know appearing out of this dark cave
and then looking after we see these
shadows and trying to make sense of the
world do you think that there's a value
i mean we often hear pejoratives you
know about philosophy about
you know philosophy of science you know
people
varying degrees of the old canard that
you know science needs philosophers the
way that you know birds need
ornithologists or something like that
but you know i find philosophy to be so
rich and so
um and just so enjoyable and i feel that
to not teach it or you know even worse
to be pejorative insulting towards it i
think we do our physics students a
disservice what do you think about this
how can we make it more besides buying
all your books and using them in our
classes but but
in reality how can we dispel this rumor
that's that philosophy is is not useful
imagine if birds were were equipped with
knowledge of ornithology yeah i mean
they would really they would really have
it made
you know if they knew their own behavior
patterns and all of that they they would
really just kill it
so yeah i think uh
i i think philosophy is really important
and in particular when it comes to
physics because i think you know what
has happened and
it's weird and unfortunate i think
and i'm not a sociologist so i don't
know if this picture is exactly right
but if you look at um
you know you look at some of the greats
in physics uh from you know so boltzmann
maxwell
einstein all these people they've read a
lot of philosophy you know so
einstein talks about you know hume david
hume inspired him
uh galileo and they came out right
yeah so you've
had this was hugely important
and then you go uh but it was part of
law philosophy is part of the german
uh training and a lot of the theoretical
physicists were german right
now you know you go to now fast forward
to after the war
now america is an ascendancy in the
sciences you have the government putting
a ton of money into the sciences
who's not popular the germans
and then you have people who are like
some of the greatest philosophers i
think have ever existed going around
saying they don't like philosophy like
feynman yeah so feina is philosophically
gifted but he would again again say
doesn't like philosophy
as he's basically doing it right and
then you have you know like hawking in
his last book he starts off with you
know philosophy is dead right and then
the whole book is basically a uh
some philosophy of science right where
he has this kind of multi-picture
you know given up on a grand unified
theory in this kind of multi-picture
thing it's all philosophy of science
yeah but he doesn't know his philosophy
of science and he says he hates
philosophy yeah he disparages the thing
that he's actually
engaging in and so you have this kind of
uh you know shut up and calculate
attitude happen
coinciding with this
sociological pressures and then also
about the rise of grants and all that as
well where
it's harder to hard to get a grant for
would einstein have got a grant for
is
either you know either of his relativity
the special or general relativity right
you know probably not right
you would have gotten it for his quantum
mechanical uh misgivings i'm sure
because does turn out not to be
fruitful yeah so i see the other side so
i see the people who are leaving physics
i mean almost by you know by definition
i end up seeing the people who are
leaving physics they start off in
physics and then they
are not satisfied that they don't get to
talk about you know what uh
you know what quantum mechanics means
and different interpretations and detail
and quantum mechanics and that
so
i mean to i don't get i don't get
refugees from cosmology physics not too
much because it's so philosophical yeah
i mean yeah sometimes
scratch that itch yeah because we you
know as hoyle used to say you know all
these cosmologists you know are in love
with the big bang because it satisfies
their philosophical needs or their
theological needs to believe in genesis
account of creation
but i did find a more ancient uh kind of
upgrading of philosophy
in uh in galileo's cedirius nuncius
where he talks about the telescope which
he was using at the time to in his claim
resolve all the stars in the milky way
the glow of the milky way's milkiness
into individual stars and he says thus
we have proven with visible via visible
certainty
uh these issues that have for so many
generations
vexed philosophers in other words he's
saying like you guys could speculate but
one use of the telescope will prove to
you that it's right and i point out in
my book losing the nobel prize he was
actually wrong about that it was
confirmation bias and he we can't
resolve all the all the milkiness of the
milky way into stars but no matter how
big your telescope is despite what
galileo said because it's not made of
stars it's glowing dust the villain of
my book as i gave you a little grain of
earlier today uh and so you know i think
it's it has a historical precedent but
uh but the fact that i always feel like
by not observing it or not you know
learning from philosophers and
philosophers of all kinds that were you
know we're kind of doing a disservice to
to our scientists but you know it's like
we have so much to teach them it's like
do we require that they have a
a course in this one thing i'm i'm
curious about is ethics because we i've
never taken a course or something in
ethics and you're the director of the
practical center for practical ethics
first of all what is a scientist you
know scientifically inclined you know
person who wrote a uh you know very
physically kind of thesis and has
written books you know great detail in
physics as you have um where where does
ethics come into play and what makes you
how how many hats can you possibly wear
yeah it's uh well that's a question i
ask myself all the time
yeah so i would say you know so
sometimes i i joke that it's you know it
was a midlife crisis
but that's not really true because
because you know so i've taught
environmental ethics for
20 years or more
and so i've always had this kind of
teaching interest
i i guess i just thought of it as kind
of
you know
[Music]
returning some of what i've been given
where you know if all you're worried
about is empty space times like like you
know if i'm just interested in vacuum
space times with no people or problems
or planets or particles or anything
in them then you know it's nice to at
the undergraduate level to be
doing something more than uh only that
but and then the opportunity really rose
you know came came to me to uh where i
saw i was department chair and i saw
you know here we are uc san diego i
forget where we are the sixth biggest
recipient of research age in the country
people don't appreciate this but people
on your podcast hearing your podcast
should know i mean ucsd is rivals any
school in terms of its research output
and
but we don't have really that much
ethics and you know it's very it was
very much a stem
it's very much a stem school
and if you think of all the kind of
innovation and that that happens here a
lot of it you know holds great promise
and is just amazing
on the other hand you know some of it
comes with some perils as well
and so we're sort of
by not dealing with some of it in-house
we're sort of externalizing and
outsourcing
our social responsibility right and so
i went around uh campus giving these
kind of talks talking about uh you know
so we were founded by i could have
dinner with them once when when i first
came with herb york
uh and you know he worked uh in the
manhattan project right but then he's
worked on nuclear deterrence the rest of
the right there's a book about that paul
revell discovers climate change then he
comes back from harvard and uh
becomes a professor of social policy
trying to
pick up the ways to deal with it
and so we have this great in our dna
this great history of these great
scientists finding these amazing you
know making this
amazing discoveries and innovation
but then also trying to deal with the
social repercussions
and so i thought
this was a good message and it sort of
sold and we got this institute and
we've been trying to develop that
institute and
then as i've been doing that
so maybe the same has happened with you
at the uh science fiction center and in
this podcast
you know if you spend a certain amount
of time on something then you get drawn
into it more
and so now i've started working a little
bit more in practice so now my research
and teaching
sides have blurred a bit and so now i'm
starting to work a little bit more in
in practical ethics and in terms of the
meaning of that of that phrase practical
ethics is it that
application to the research side of what
ucsd does or is it
you know categorical imperatives and
kind of bigger picture things
yeah we're trying to make it more uh
yeah practical in a sense of you know
connecting to
science that's done on campus that well
it doesn't have to be done on campus
sure often is
so for instance you know we have a uh
we've had a great partnership with the
biologists working on gene drives
so gene drives our way of modifying uh
genetically modifying an organism
not like old-fashioned stuff where you
just modify the individual it either
passes the trade on or it doesn't
this one you can force it to pass it on
so it unleashes this kind of
genetic chain react irreversible chain
reaction
so it can be used for amazing things you
know so it you know they're working on
making them uh
making it so that
mosquitoes can't transmit malaria
and then all the children won't be able
to do that and they would just keep
going and keep going so be amazingly
efficient right in principle it would
never work this way but in principle you
could drop
one mosquito
you know in
an affected area in africa
and all the mosquitoes eventually would
be
sterilized or or you know this was
before unable to transmit it anyway
um
of course that's the ideal
thing that won't really work but
uh but of course you know this will
change the ecological repercussions
uh what are the what is the
long-term uh consequences of having this
kind of um
genetic technology out there in nature
so we have you know partnerships with
them and
we'll look at some of all the different
ethical aspects of that
it could be all sorts of things you know
autonomous cars
brain organoids uh all sorts of things
yeah the kind of stuff we're working on
on the arthur's clark center for human
imagination
um and so getting back to you know some
of these figures that i have figure you
know finger puppets up or working on
yours a calendar uh finger puppet as
well but um one of the characters is
kirk girdle who spends an awful lot of
time uh in the book at least talking
about his universe and i wanna because
it is um is relatively unfamiliar to
many of the listeners out there who know
the kind of you know friedman robertson
walker you know kind of description
lemaitre big bang but the this type of
universe which is very special that
girdle thought about
is is very much not not in vogue uh
maybe for good reason but i want to
explore some of the different space
times that you do talk about sterile
though they may be like these mosquitoes
hopefully uh will eventually be uh beast
i've always wondered you know what is
the purpose of the mosquito you know if
you could if you could figure out why
does that mosquito turns out there's a
book written about it it's called like
um
apex predator or something because it's
yeah people ask what animal in africa
has killed the most human beings and
it's like the hippo you know the tiger
no it's it's the mosquito and uh and the
guy goes through like some of the ways
that the mosquito changed history
including in the revolutionary war when
apparently you know the swamps and
eastern seaboard or whatever of america
uh were uh riven with mosquitoes and the
british had less immunity to malaria or
something or they didn't they didn't
have quiet
i don't know the details but
apparently the mosquito played a role in
the and the victory by the colonists
against the british empire so i know
this book uh i haven't read it yet yeah
it's a it's a very fascinating because
everything that yeah there could be
these downstream effects you talk a lot
in your book in the graphic novel about
time travel you know can you go back and
and uh you know and and kill the
dinosaurs you know before the asteroid
or give them a space program before the
asteroid hits or or go back and kill
your grandfather before he meets your
grandmother um and so all those all
these kind of paradoxes but i want to
focus a little bit more first on the top
level on the cosmological side of things
because my a lot of my audience is
interested in that can you explain a
little bit about girdles universe
why it was important and why he
allegedly on his deathbed asked
his attendee or whoever was there what
about the universe did they find it to
be rotating this is a story that i've
i've read uh actually in a book about
girdle all right so people still do
write books about this rotating universe
so yeah what's the appeal of it what was
the idea behind it
yeah so
yeah girdle was at the institute for uh
advanced study at princeton
and he lived near einstein and they
would walk home together
and so girdle was not a physicist but he
was the greatest logician of all time
in fact before
uh the girdling completeness theorem was
the greatest theorem in logic of all
time he was already the greatest
magician of all time right and then he
did that so he's like got extra
anyway so what i'm trying to say is he's
really really smart
uh
so he's you know talking to him too
smart for his own good right because he
tried to get he talked to einstein when
he was becoming a citizen and allegedly
said there's a contradiction in the
united states constitution logical
inconsistency and einstein said ah keep
that to yourself until after
but anyway yeah go on so he was talking
to einstein about cosmology uh in
spacetime yeah and then he he discovered
a solution and you know it's very you
know if you i don't know how many of you
uh
you know listeners know i mean the
einstein field equation is very you know
it looks so pretty you know
uh you know uh science is so pretty and
beautiful and elegant and uh you know
because you've got basic you know g
equals eight pi t you think oh that's
beautiful really it's you know
i don't know what like uh
100 something uh partial couple of
partial differentials
so if you solve it you know you get your
name
after it right came up with this
solution
which i think is
it's possibly the coolest solution in
terms of
uh because it has very cool uh
consequences of what you can do so in
particular you could time travel through
any from any point to any other point in
verbal space time
uh but the uh what's cool about it is it
doesn't happen from any kind of cheesy
math tricks
so like you could take you know if you
took a piece of paper you said let this
be space time you know this part is time
this part of space
and then i roll it and i attach these
two
then you can say well like it's time
travel by going around like that
that's cheesy because you did this kind
of cut and paste
wormholes but now the girdle space time
is it's topologically euclidean so
there's nothing
it's simply connected yeah it says no
holes or anything like that coffee cup
genus number is zero right it's even the
temporally orientable which means that
every single event you could draw a
little arrow
and have a consistent arrow drawing
everywhere to the future or in space
the vector is cheesy
and so yeah so even on a closed
time-like curve you could still draw
arrows consistently around that curve
and so unlike a mobius strip which is
not orientable exactly
and so it doesn't have any kind of
shenanigans like like the
uh maybe a strip or that
and yet there it is it's not so it's got
two things that are really weird so one
is that you could try to travel from any
point to any other point
and so yeah the universe looks like it's
all the matter is rotating around you
and it looks that way every single from
every single direction
and what this does is it sort of tips
the you know as you go out from any
point it's going to seem like that
to you and the when you're looking at
the picture of it you know the the
light cones are going to be seem like
they're tipping over
and
that's going to and as you go outward if
you accelerate you'll be able to spiral
around
and go back and say visit your birth
the other really weird thing and i think
this is what he thought was actually the
weirdest thing about it
was that because
all that you know all the light cones
tip over
you can't
uh
draw a continue a global instantaneous
slice of time
so if you say well i want my splice of
time to be entirely space-like you know
an instant of time should be all
space-like
there is no global such slice because as
you start to draw extend it out it
becomes uh time-lapse
because the light goes tipping over into
it and so it
yeah so when if you tried to stay top
space like it wouldn't
you you can't do it
so you can't then think this really
disturbed them
uh i think more than the time travel
because you can't then think of the
universe as sort of
unfolding
in some
kind of uh you know tense
yeah
whereas like in the other
you know in the in the more famous
cosmological models you know like
friedman roberts and walker
you know it's still relativistic and so
you could have you know
uh different observers you know
measuring time differently and all that
but uh but you could you know you could
uh you know pick particular uh well
there you usually use these you know
co-moving coordinates and
pick a particular frame
but anyway the point is you could pick a
cosmic time
and then think of the universe as
evolving according to that cosmic time
but you just can't do that there's no
cosmic time in in lateral
space-time and there's no expansion
either right
no
and yeah so it's it's not our space-time
sure no
as you said you know
just for the listener that may not be
conversing with this
as you said earlier you know you solve
the einstein's equation in almost any
context and you get your name on it and
uh many people have tried to do it and
there's very few that have their names
on these models so to come up with
anyone um you know let alone one that
comports with you know cosmology uh you
know reasonable observations and
cosmology is a triumph you know
mathematically i guess the question that
you know i have is is you know did he
believe in it because it was before that
really dispositive evidence of
of um you know expansion that that
hubble and his collab and actually
hubble's early data were incredibly you
know coarse and not this positive right
until the 30s 40s 50s that got better
and better and even until the you know
50s and 60s people had arguments with
the big bang you know it wasn't even the
universe was expanding was was not taken
seriously including by the inhabitant
former inhabitant of this office jeffrey
burbidge
who with his colleague fred hoyle uh
they went to their graves believing in
the uh in the falsity of the big bang
model and the and the truth of the
quasi-steady state so it wasn't nearly
as accepted even when girdle was alive
so did he believe it or did he think oh
it's really cool for a logician to make
you know to get his name on
i don't think he believed it
although i think there were
attempts to tinker with it to make it a
little more
connect you know possible that it might
be possible in some way to accommodate
the data
uh but he had this really
curious argument uh
and you know philosophers have puzzled
about this argument for a long time
because he
he says there's this girdle universe
you know this you know his solution
it's a solution to the laws of nature
the einstein field equations
and then he says that that showed that
time in our world which is not the
girdle world
is ideal
and by ideally i think he means you know
just
affection of our you know due to us not
due to the world
and so then
now you look at this argument and you
think
what is the argument exactly here this
is very puzzling and some people would
point out they'd say
um you can't go from
you know there's a possible there's a
possible world
to
a fact about this world you know so
there's a possible world where there are
unicorns that doesn't mean they're
unicorns here
and to this
so some people point this out and then i
think well this is crazy because we're
talking about the world's greatest
logician right so he didn't make an
elementary logic mistake
[Music]
that's clearly not what's going on
and so i think what he thought is that
what he called this lapse of time you
know in what you refer to as a tense
i think that thought that was essential
to time
and that there was a
a
world that obeyed our laws
but didn't have that time then meant
that here
too it might not be that you know that
that that's not a feature of time even
here
so the t is still the t right and the t
in the girl universe is still the t and
the
you know
whatever universe we're in some kind of
freed money and free money and thing
and so if it and so if it didn't have
lapse there it's not lapse in here
and so it must just be that we sort of
attribute the lapse to to it it's not
fun it's not fundamental interesting
um but we don't really know exactly what
the argument was be cool to work out you
know if it were
because the the you know the implication
is yeah it's sort of the time is
emergent or fictional or maybe not
intrinsically fundamental you know part
of elementary reality
and you see a lot of these things that
come out you know i had carlo revelli on
my podcast which the episode will
be out before this one most likely i had
roger penrose on three or four times
here's his book cycles of time where he
has this alternative model uh which has
the universe never really experiencing
the big bang or the inflationary epoch
that many cosmologists dominant you know
kind of prevailing model right now
although it seems to lack decisive
evidence we may be in this poparian you
know no man's land where we can't
falsify inflation because it could have
happened but without enough energy to
produce waves of gravity that my
colleagues and i can detect
on the other hand it could be that some
alternative cosmology took place but
they don't make any falsifiable
predictions such as roger's model it
would just be you wouldn't observe
gravitational waves because there is no
inflationary field to nucleate these you
know quantum quanta of gravity i want to
ask you a question that i keep asking
and you mentioned it in the book as well
but i asked roger and i asked you know
people like lenny suskind and frank
wilcek
we we kind of use at least to me a
circular type of logic which is to say
that you know we need to understand and
have a quantum theory of gravity because
we don't understand uh the physics and
extremely strong you know quantum
physics and extremely strong
gravitational scenarios such as at the
singular near the singularity of a black
hole
and uh and such as at the origin of the
of time or the big bang as as we might
say and i point out that both of those
regimes are on unverifiable or
inaccessible we can't get any
information out from a singularity we
can get some notion of things in the
event horizon of black hole but no more
um you know hawking and and uh and
penrose singularity theorems you know
basically
show that you're never going to be able
to get back to absolute zero in time if
it indeed exists and roger doesn't even
believe there's an absolute zero of time
he believes in a cyclic cycle of aeons
as he calls them so why are we so
concerned with this theory of everything
involving quantizing gravity if the only
two regimes in which we can observe it
would be
on observable or where it becomes
applicable rather are unobservable
yeah it's a good question i mean i
i hope
that there would be some regime where
it's observable
and i would expect it to be actually in
in in cosmology
uh is that that's the biggest yeah
that's the biggest lab where
and so it's running these natural
experiments that we can't run right uh
and so i would hope that some of these
things would you know so they seem
really really really you know so we're
going to measure
you know so that the electrons have mass
there should be a gravitational effect
you know
inside the tiniest you know and just
hydrogen that making some sort of little
we should be able to make a little
gravitational corrections for for
whatever is going on there
and then inside you know and then when
things clump you know when a star clumps
up really really tight and there should
be
that there's got to be quantum effects
that at a certain scale
and so we know that there is some
physics that we don't know
that must
operate in these cases i think
uh so i think that's where we're kind of
safe
are there are there
but those two cases as you just pointed
out those two cases are cases that we're
not going to ever observe
but it could be that there's um
you know i don't know if i mean there
might be something
bootstrappy about this but if
if we think of different so
there's some work and different
interpretations of quantum mechanics
so uh roger penrose has stuff like this
where suppose you put in like a
realistic collapse mechanism so the
quantum wave function collapsed a
certain and you have a
very specific sort of trigger for what
does that
that might show itself
in
you know
well who knows
it would be more question uh for uh
uh
for you you know what does it show
itself in the fluctuations does it show
itself over extended over time through
the universe
uh so
so some of those theories will depart
from
uh
they'll have they'll make predictions
that are actually uh
non-standard that you could actually
test
maybe rule out
yeah so when i uh i think about that
first of all yeah you so i don't answer
any questions on my own podcast i'm just
kidding that's my prerogative
i actually was interviewed by barry
barrish for my own podcast uh two weeks
ago at his house in
los angeles which is kind of a treat so
i was answering his questions about why
i'm so bitter and so forth about not
winning the nobel prize but that's for
another subject stay tuned for that
special episode
but um but thinking about that you know
in just a little bit more depth this
concept of a singularity is is
intimately connected with both the black
hole and potentially with the big bang
and
of course even observing these waves of
gravity via their imprint on the causing
microwave backgrounds b mode
polarization technically wouldn't take
us back to t equals zero it would be you
know a thousand planck times or so
you'll be significantly after in plank
units the or the origin of time or the
singularity itself
my question you know is kind of maybe
it's philosophical but i almost see a
zeno's paradox like effect where we have
no examples of something in the universe
that is a singularity is infinite uh
because in order for something to be
infinite as you you know remember from
your kids you tell them i love you
infinity they say i love you infinity
plus one
you know infinity minus one would have
to be the temperature of the universe
you know one planck time after the
origin of the universe then infinity
minus but infinity minus one is infinity
so these questions of singularities are
kind of perplexing in that
we kind of are led to believe that they
exist
by extrapolation from our current time
but you know predictions about the
future as yogi berra said are very
uncertain it's hard to make them but
even predictions about the past when
they involve singularities since we have
no singularity evidence of any quantity
that is infinite why do we think you
know why don't we put so much stock in
the existence of singularities
philosophically speaking
yeah uh
well they're very disturbing because you
don't know
well hey you don't know what they are i
mean even even in general relativity
when you when we talk about singularity
well the singularity theorems just show
that you know
all the world lines run at you know are
incomplete
right so they don't actually show
there's like a a whole
so there's three notions of singularity
right it says uh sort of
this incomplete notion you know so jd
secrets called it gd sticking
completeness
then there's this sort of idea of uh
kind of curvature blow up
where then there your there's your
infinity
uh you know so now that the curvature
goes up
and then you get this idea of like a
hole
like like a little point has been
blocked out like a kind of open right
open sewer cap in space time where you
just went walking and then right not a
coordinated singularity actual
singularity right man covered not
replaced yeah and then uh what's i don't
know it's kind of interesting i think
that you know in a in a in the kind of
geometry that you do classical physics
those notions coincide
and then you go to uh
so in relativity you use what's called a
pseudo-romanian geometry and then those
notions come apart
and so we sort of
think of the incompleteness as a maybe
it's like a indicator or symptom of the
other things
but we don't really know
so what the heck is a singularity
at all
anyway and then why is it you know
everyone says well general relativity
sells the seeds of its own demise by
predicting these singularities but then
you think well why
why is that so bad actually if it does
have
this incompleteness
those are all corrections to the formal
infinities that arose from considering
you know coulomb effects and
infinitesimal distances i mean maybe i'm
just you know thinking aloud here but uh
i mean maybe the reason we don't like it
is because all the places we see
singularities elsewhere in physics we
don't really believe in them we think of
them as part of the representation of
the physics right
so like
the example i like is you know of a
water drop coming out of your faucet
and you know when you model it physics
physically
the water drop never breaks you know
just sort of gets in it gets right
infinitely thin yeah
and then what you have to do is with
your mind bring in some scissors and cut
it
or just see well we know what real water
drops do before right and so there's
something is
you know there's a mismatch there
between the mathematical representation
and the reality
and so we have no problem bringing out
our mental scissors and sniffing right
right and it's something you know
computers uh yeah speaking of water uh
you should you should enjoy some um yeah
i mean computers can't handle it we have
you know not a number we have things it
seems like the human mind is the unique
entity that we know that can conceive of
infinity and in fact multiple levels as
you know of infinity there's different
degrees
of infinity um as my kids will point out
when they say you should have said you
love me infinity plus one then they'll
say infinity squared then they'll say
all f-zero
but you know i got some uh some
annoyingly precocious kids but the but
the you know kind of this thing that is
so baffling i think is so resilient to
understanding is what makes time so
interesting there's so many books about
time i just re-read a brief history of
time by stephen hawking and i read it
first when i was 16 or 17 you probably
were excited by it when it came out and
i didn't understand it and i remember
going to see
and hear stephen hawking speak in 95 at
the royal astronomical society meeting
in london and that was back when he
could still respond and quasi real time
using you know his finger and his eyes
and someone asked him you know professor
hong why'd you write this book nobody
understands it it's rumored that people
have never even completed it even you
you know from cover to cover why'd you
write this book and he replied and that
you know uh that that the kind of iconic
iconic voice of his
if such a thing can be said you know
because my daughter needed to go to
college and i had leonard malone now on
uh the podcast uh about a month ago and
he was talking in all seriousness he and
i about you know the need for hawking to
have a basic corporate function that he
needed to support his medical care he
needed to support his kids his ex-wife
is you know whatever it is
and uh it was a real need for him but in
that book the last sentence i was
tweeting about this yesterday you know
the last sentence in that book is you
know if we could you know finally come
up with a origin story for you know how
time begins something like that then we
would glimpse the mind of god and it
kind of brings up you know this next
question first of all why are physicists
so you know in love with talking about
god particles the mind of god god not
playing dice but we won't get into that
now for such an atheistically inclined
uh body of of humans um but i want to
ask you in the context of you know time
we have so many different
interpretations carlo ravelli roger
penrose
can they all be right i mean can they
all be
can they all be seeing the same aspects
of the elephant than just describing it
differently or to what extent is there a
theory of time
um yeah i think
i think there could be some winners and
some losers here uh i mean whether we
would ever know who is who i don't know
but uh
the uh
to me i i divided into us basically
two sorts of people you know so
you know what's going on i think what
makes time so fascinating and why there
are so many books and all of this is
because well hey i i think it was
with up there with consciousness of one
of the last great mysteries
and why is it such a mystery
i mean physics has a
time variable in it physics is one of
our best theories it's you know
when we just
put a
you know a uh
wrote another rover on mars a helicopter
helicopter i mean it was unbelievable
it's one of them and and that and all of
those and all of that theory required
a time variable right and so that's all
indirect confirmation for the way
physics considers time newtonian time at
that right yeah
and in relativity to get to mars but i
think what makes it so interesting is
because you know our experience of time
is
just so so
divorced from this and so just like with
the problem of consciousness
you know you could look at you know all
you want of brain scans and you're not
going to see anything you know you're
not and they're going to dig around the
mind and then find a little a little you
there
[Music]
and so with time you have this massive
you know you've got this idea of this
flowing now
and
you know so you divide the world into
past present future and then this
present moves
and
also you endow the past and the future
with different things you end up you
think the past is fixed and settled the
future is open
you know so where i would i can't you
know there's no knob i can
i can uh
uh toggle that's going to change where i
was born
but there's a lot of buttons i can press
that
would change where i died right
and so you have these massive
differences
but now you look over at physics and you
don't see any of that right i don't see
the past and future i don't see a
distinguished present and i don't see
differences between the past and future
right
and so
you have this gap
and then i mean that's where i i
got had this kind of i was working on
all these kind of physics topics
earlier in my career
and then uh when i came here there you
know we were so good in cognitive
science and there are all these people
working on time perception and that like
got talking to them and all of a sudden
i realized you know that
there's not a good theory of how
you know
it seems crazy that to me still that you
don't have a good theory of how
uh
you know the interaction between
physical time and sort of human time
and
so physicists you'll have all these
we'll make side comments every now and
then so like in brian green's book he'll
talk about memory
and talk and have a proto theory of how
this works
seems perfectly fine to me but but
basically they say oh but all that
flowing stuff it's an illusion
so what they're doing is they're taking
the problem they're taking off the desk
of the physicist and putting it on the
desk of the psychologist
by saying it's an illusion but then
but then the psychologist doesn't know
what's on their desk right cognizant so
then it comes to the then you know the
philosophers are on the floor
and so we we get to whatever falls off
the desk of a desk
and so then i had this idea of you know
trying to explain this and really do it
kind of a little bit rigorously
and so this is not in my cartoon book
but in the other book
and the kind of picture i have is
you know i'm wondering you know so we've
got this critter who's going around
let's say in a relativistic world
so so physics is right about time
but they model time in this kind of
tense flowing way
why would they do that
and so i try to show is that it would
make sense in such a world
uh even if the world isn't like that
uh given the environment given the
thermodynamic arrow
given the kind of challenges that we as
organisms face
and so the way i think it is so i
thought it's a little bit more like on
the model of color
so you don't think of you know
fundamental
you know hydrogen what color is it you
know
you don't think if a
fundamental world is
colored
you know that it has to do with um
you know the the type of creature you
are and the relationship
the relationship you are have with it so
it's not just physics because it's not
just the surface reflectance profile
right it's also you know how many
types of how many rods and cones do i
have and what types what type of
creature imi
and then he that opens up a kind of once
you start thinking about this way it
opens up a a fascinating avenue to
explore that is still being explored
which is you know why did that why does
that creature have that that rotten cone
structure
well you know now look look at the
colors of the fruits and stuff like this
what type of fruits does it eat and then
but then of course now the evolutionary
story is very complicated because maybe
the fruits developed that way because
they were creatures to eat them
but then you could think about the same
kind of thing with time now where you
think
well so i i do
think of you know some events
simultaneous and some not think of these
two snaps
uh
bob garage i think in his book says that
in your reference frame that you have to
do the snaps within one billionth of a
second to get them
space-like related to each other because
they're fun yeah yeah yeah and
anyway so they're
you know so one is after the other most
likely but i'm still judging them you
know some of them are simultaneous and
some not
but why
doing this with
audio and and visual matching
and then i started looking at the you
know different people who do it
differently
so there's a
retired pilot in england who had a
small lesion in his brain and
he will um
forget which way it goes he if you say
hi to him he'll see your lips move
and then hear you
or maybe he'll hear you first and then
see the lips move
an observable gap it's like 256 250
milliseconds
difference
which is roughly like halfway
it's like halfway you know when
a major league pitcher when they pitch
it's sort of like
halfway across
the
halfway to home plate
just for completely conscious and
observable
and so you have
so and then it turns out that you know
he's sort of an outlier but not really
because every single any two people it's
it seems have statistically significant
differences in what things they bind
together as simultaneous
so you and i in this room if we could
label all the events and if they're
happening fast enough you and i would
differ we would differ on a whole bunch
of things so if i said you know brian
what's
simultaneous with that snap and you had
to write that list down right and i did
it we would have different lists right
some people are more you know more
accurate in terms of absolute global
time i'm sure the others right and it's
like musical ability like i have no
musical bill or language ability or
something yeah we probably all have
different
different abilities yeah and uh
actually music is particularly
interesting with this because you know
you
you'll habituate your you know so if you
are playing uh the organ at king's
king's college cambridge
you know the the lag between you
pressing the button and the actual noise
is huge
but you will gradually erase that lag
and it will seem simultaneous to you oh
okay so there's all that kind of thing
going on
and yet we don't notice any of it right
right because
when i do the snap the noise is actually
made by my finger it's here yeah
but you know there are people who are
sound firsters and light firsters yeah
depending on
you know others that are touched right
yeah and so some of them might hear the
noise when it's there yeah others when
it's been sitting there for a while
but it's simply crazy to think
that it wasn't this snap that caused you
to hear that noise right and so you
don't have disagreement sorry there's
wild
massive
hidden disagreement but massive uh
agreement about what things happen now
uh but you know if we change the speed
you know the relative velocities of
things that we were
you know had to deal with and all this
stuff if you had like time dilation in
your face where you were meeting people
optimistically yeah
then
you know would we have come up with this
kind of flowing now picture
uh
the
and then i started to actually also
think about animals and stuff you know
so
you know seals they spend so much time
underwater
speed of sound is so different
underwater than above how do they sync
their audio and audio and visual
giraffes
the when they're moving you know their
hoof
you know that that nerf the signals up
the nerves are pretty slow i forget the
speed but not super fast it's gonna go
all the way up to the head right all the
way back to you know 19 19 times two 18
feet
that's uh yeah in the book i joke about
yeah the giraffe maybe has not only a
long neck but a long now
[Laughter]
that's great well the last couple of
minutes before at least i have to go and
uh take the time to go pick up kids at
carpool um there's this notion that i
hear a lot about and i can't tell if
it's ultimately
uh trivial or if there's something
really rich that's just being lost in my
obtuse self and that's this notion of a
block universe uh what what is that what
is it relevant is it just a convenient
way of thinking about it as you know
kind of a god's perspective if if such a
thing could be conceived of so yeah what
is this block universe that that people
it seems to be in vogue now to the
extent that such a thing can be
yeah so in philosophy they they think of
this two they think there's roughly two
types of theory this kind of tense
theory where you've got this kind of
moving now
intense not physically tense but that's
right past tense present tense
um and then and then if you remove all
the tents then what you've got is a
block
uh
so you could think of it this way like
if you you know if you you come acro you
know you're wandering around on campus
lost you see one of these maps and so
the block universe is like the map
the tense theory is like the map with
the red dot
you know that says you are here now
right uh yeah and so this is the so
that's the spatial version of this
and so a lot of people say physics
uh is you know
implies the block universe because
there's no
it's a there's no red dot
physics doesn't give you a red dot right
and then you know somebody like me then
thinks well the red dot is sort of
formed by all the relationships
there it's there's not really an extra
thing in the world that's the red dot
it's just
it's just
you know your consciousness is at that
location and then
it seems like
because it seems like you're you're the
violet and all you think that that's
special
but there's nothing really special
um
that said so there's this debate between
the block the blockers and the
non-blockers
i actually have a kind of minority view
and in philosophy whereas i i think the
two views are the same
so i think that redescriptions are the
same thing
unless you deliberately make them
different uh
so that is
yeah when i say you know so the i
so the block universe will you know the
block the blocker will say
you know
dinosaurs they exist
they just exist you know just like
things exist just spatially distant from
you but you can't see them the things
that exist temporally distant from you
they exist
they're all there on the block the
dinosaurs are there
the uh but you know but it's early but
that there is earlier than
the
moment of utterance when we're speaking
right now
uh
now the
the tensor uh they think well no only
that the only thing that exists is the
present
but now they've got a problem because
there used to be those dinosaurs so then
they have to say something
about those dinosaurs because those
dinosaurs aren't
they're not just like a fiction like
alice in wonderland or something that
they you know they used to be here right
so
now they have to say something whenever
they say that thing
you can then translate that into the
block
that it exists
so i think you can translate back and
forth without loss
does that mean that the same theory
who knows it's hard to say when there's
two representations of the same thing
versus two different representations but
if but if the two representations don't
do any work either of them do any work
that the other one doesn't
then it inclines me to think that
they're really the same right and so to
me i think it's this huge fuss for a
hundred years
since mctaggart this famous philosopher
in 1908 wrote this paper
been this huge fl uh fuss fighting over
this and i think it's all
uh much ado about what's to do about
nothing more than it is
on your philosophy yeah because i think
if you have that tense view
it doesn't actually explain your
experience in any way right and so if it
doesn't do any explanatory work then i
don't really
but they often say it does
but it doesn't and so if it doesn't then
i don't see why i want to bother
fighting about a teleological purpose to
it yeah
great well that cleared up something for
me and uh just want to remark how
much i'm looking forward to taking your
class either in person or remotely on
pseudoscience i can surely provide you
with many examples of how i practice
pseudoscience so quite frequently after
i buy my lottery ticking get my palm
read and get my horoscope read i will
have plenty of fodder for you craig
calendar director of the center for
practical ethics here at uc san diego a
treasured colleague and i think though
not the first ucsd professor on the
first philosopher on the podcast so i
want to commend you for that yes and i
have some parting gifts for you
including finger puppets and uh space
dust so greg thank you so much i hope we
can do a part two someday in the future
if such a thing could be said to exist
yes thank you very much
thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
you